la façon dont je pense que tout le monde obtient un
miracle mon miracle était que je me suis retrouvé à vivre en
face de Margo Roth
Spiegelman
elle était sans doute la créature la plus magnifique
que Dieu ait jamais créée
la vie de Margo était une série d'
aventures incroyablement épiques
allez-vous passer le  le reste du lycée se
languissant de cette fille
une année senior touchait à sa fin Margo et
moi étions pratiquement des étrangers jusqu'à
cette nuit ce que l'Argo j'ai besoin d'emprunter
votre voiture ce que j'ai neuf choses que je dois
faire ce soir pouvez-vous juste obtenir votre
petit ami  pour le faire
ex-petit ami mon petit ami
m'a trompé l'intrigue de vengeance commence aussi
bizarre que ça en a l'air je
ne peux pas croire que tu viens de faire ça prends la
photo maintenant d'accord maintenant c'était amusant
on y va mon cœur bat ma poitrine c'est
le chemin  tu devrais ressentir toute ta vie
c'est beau c'est une ville de papier
maisons de papier et gens de papier tout est
plus moche de près n'est-ce pas que les
choses vont être différentes
j'espère vraiment que
Margo a toujours aimé les mystères peut-être s  il l'
aimait tellement elle en est devenue une elle est
partie la dernière fois que tu as vu Margo tu
étais avec elle hier soir ça
doit vouloir dire quelque chose c'est quelque chose dans
la fenêtre de Margo elle a laissé de petits indices
comme des miettes de pain j'ai trouvé quelque chose
je pense qu'elle t'envoie un  message viens
me trouver nous essayons si fort tu iras
à Paper Towns et tu ne reviendras jamais
je pense que je sais où elle pourrait être
je vais avec toi elle va je
vais certainement prendre un risque
jouer si prudemment c'est peut-être ce
qu'elle a essayé de me dire tout le
temps que puis-je dire quelle mission Hé
tu l'aimes bien ouais je fais
tout le monde obtient un miracle Maya miracle est
Margo Roth Spiegelman
toi